I just didn't care how I felt previously
if I was jacked but felt like that was
worth it I'm 18 years old I'm super
super skinny like 63 kilos like 130
pounds super super small when I get to
UNI I wanted to be more attractive to
girls I wanted to feel more confident so
I started training just total bro split
and this is what 2006 2007. I remember
the day that I broke 70 kilos I was like
21 and I was like wow like a massive 71
kilos it's huge and then it got towards
maybe 24 25 and I was just a bit sick I
was kind of bored of doing more bro
split type stuff so I went on to do Thai
boxing why Thai I went out to Thailand
and fought out there which was fun then
came back got into CrossFit
2016-17 previously it was something I
did to just look good whereas now it's
something that I do to feel good